ah là le job ça va être déjà de mettre
en place des outils communication qui
pour certains n'existe pas de réévaluer
d'autres outils de communication en
particulier sur la communication d
digitale numérique donc les réseaux
sociaux la com numérique qui aujourd'hui
est quand même un des gros instruments
du buzz pour des disciplines comme les
nôtres et surtout pour des tout petits
budgets voire pour pas de budget du tout
hein ce qui est un peu le une constante
dans toutes les ligues sportives et
comités sportif c'est de faire au
moindre coût simplement parce queon a
des problèmes budgétaires et là tu vois
c'est le truc truc que je te disais
d'Instagram d'accord donc là ils ont
fait la publication ça c'est un truc
aussi qu'on va discuter c'est la
question de
l'Instagram qu'est-ce que tu pourquoi tu
fais ça
qu'est-ce alors moi déjà je suis judo
oui oui il y a il y a un gap énorme qui
est lié au moyen au moyens et aux
méthodes et les méthodes n'étant pas
elles-mêmes toujours lié au moyen la
méthode c'est véritablement
euh le professionnalisme c'est le
professionnalisme et c'est parfois parce
que c'est du bénévola et c'est aussi la
grandeur du bénévolat c'est de se dire
je ne sais pas faire mais j'ai envie de
faire alors j'y vais je vais soutenir ça
c'est un truc qui me plat tout et la
Ligue de judo c'est une association et
tous les gens qui contribuent que ce
soit sur le plan sportif le plan
logistique et tout sont des gens de
bonne volonté et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose d'essentiel qu'on ne
retrouve pas forcément en milieu
professionnel
on se dira c'est gagner lorsque on
arrivera à se définir justement dans cet
espace de bénévolat un tableau
d'objectif puis ce sera gagné quand on
verra beaucoup plus notre discipline
puis que l'objectif ultime c'est ça et
laavir sous tous ces aspects pas
uniquement la compétition parce que les
Jeux des îles c'est une vitrine de la
compétition et du très haut niveau mais
le judo c'est autre chose c'est des
valeurs c'est de l'entraide de la
solidarité c'est l'abnégation c'est
l'altruisme c'est l'oubli de soi et
c'est se donner aux autres et ça c'est
un truc qui qui doit
passer